an entire industry Hollywood which is
now beginning to crumble we have a
headline from CBS Hollywood drama actors
join writers in Striking against
producers I want to show you this
interesting uh moment on a podcast that
I saw a comedian Theo Von and actor Adam
DeVine who you've seen in a whole bunch
of things they were talking about how
just as I just said that once you allow
wokeness into something and in their uh
what they're discussing is comedy and
movies once you allow it in it will
destroy the whole freaking thing take a
look they there used to be something
like every Studio would put out several
comedies every every year and there was
like 45 or 46 comedies in the theaters
every year so about every week or every
other week or so there's a new comedy in
the theaters and uh and then now last
year there was like six or seven
it's crazy it's crazy and people need
and the crazy thing is it feels like
people need comedy more than ever yeah I
feel like they want it I feel yeah so
that's what this movie was it was like
and there's no like hidden message I
feel like nowadays
people like you get to the end of what
you think is a comedy and you're like is
that about global warming yeah yeah
you're like is this is just like some
deep hidden message that I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to recycle more or like you
know yeah there has to be something else
right oh the Moon is trans is that what
yeah is that the surprising yeah yeah
okay I guess we do have to think about
that don't we yeah I agree there's
there's a lot of what was it was a great
and that's what your David Spade and uh
your movie is about is yeah trans Moon
yeah
just the people to to spread that
message oh it's about Transportation
it's about a lot of vehicles admitting
who they really are the cars wanted to
be motorcycles motorcycles wishing they
were scooters yeah it's just it's where
things are you guys get it they push out
all of this nonsense trans this Transat
there were five Transformer movies more
than meets the eye you see what I did
there not the funniest thing I've ever
said kinda you could have put in a sound
effect level do we have a warrant we
should have one of those no okay I'll
take that
um
now the issue they're making they're
actually making a good point though if
you think about what entertainment
really is so think whatever you think
for you guys what what is your favorite
comedy movie of all time mine is Naked
Gun without question Naked Gun which was
the next version of it was to me it was
airplane on steroids I was 13 years old
when I saw it I thought it was the
funniest freaking thing in the history
of the world I remember seeing it in the
movie theater a fat man who was sitting
in front of me in the aisle seat
actually fell out of his chair into the
aisle from laughing so hard but whatever
your favorite movie is whether it was
Naked Gun airplane Best in Show whatever
your whatever you love like they weren't
trying to teach you anything they were
trying to make you freaking laugh
Seinfeld's probably the best example of
that as a sitcom it was never trying to
teach you anything it was just going for
the laugh we can all think back to the
sitcoms that every now and again like
every eighth episode would suddenly be
oh my God that guy did crack and what's
gonna what we have to teach a lesson now
like these corny things but that's not
what this should be about
[Music]
oh